this my project is too epic though still
so
it's more of like um
coming for callus crown
coming for khaled's crown yeah that's
all i could say
hey shout out og shout out to khalid but
that's not a bad approach if you're
gonna put an album out right trying to
like yo let me just put a whole project
together full of hit records and i made
all the beats and you made all the beats
you get to keep all the money yeah for
sure that's always yeah well i mean
obviously you pay the artist but like
you know they get their cut but like
you're no no we do swaps you oh you do
swaps yeah so you mean to tell me
you're like hey i need this for my [ __ ]
it's all me and you get this beat or for
your albums had four beats on a future
album yeah part of the swatch yeah like
you know it's the same thing
my beats at 100kb right now 100 bands
it's like swap this is even you know
future probably won't 250 reverse and
[ __ ] like that yeah
they help the artists out like some of
the artists can't even they be hot but
they budgets don't even be can't even
pay for what i want so it's just better
anyway but if you like an artist let's
say there's a young artist who you just
[ __ ] with you're a fan of will you do a
deal on them with a beat of course i'll
just give it to them that's nice that's
a good zone
not a lot of producers in 2022 are
getting that that kind of ticket man so
congrats not a lot of producers in 202
is as rich as me either
that's a different thing